oh my god it's him it looks like him
ladies and gentlemen it is now time to watch the
book of boba fett chapter six don't know what
the title of this episode is yet because that's
how d-plus rolls guys use the force to hit the
like button subscribe and click that notification
bell if you were really satisfied with that last
episode and you want to check out our reaction
for the next one also check this out full length
watch alongs where you sync up with the time code
they're over at our patreon page massive thanks
to all of become superjects but check out all the
content that we got to offer blind wave recently
moved all their content over to our patreon page
thank you guys it's really giving us a good boost
boys at prepper thank you guys for helping us down
these highlights this is the way this is the way
this is live
we'll leave the spice and take
the credits back to mozambique
the rest will follow do you know where
you are gentlemen oh god dig it through
hell yeah load up your wares and head back to
where you came we can chalk this one
up to you guys reading the map wrong
bowls cobb shot first
sexy cowboy and every one of
those pikes was a celebrity cameo
come on let's get high
holy [ __ ]
so excited go visit some jedi
holy [ __ ] we going to the places
that we are my friend
what if we see ben solo oh dude
that'd be cool tie it all together
buddy [ __ ] oh that's shaboosh technology
eat it oh buddy i love his little try face
that has really improved yeah what's changed
why have one frog when you can have many you will
never want for frogs again all right let's go for
a walk chamook who was the guy who was hired
the deep fake guy yeah i want to tell you about
someone you remind me of a great deal and my time
in dagobah his name was yoda he was small like you
he would speak in riddles improper
english do you remember back home
would you like to remember holy [ __ ]
be okay buddy
oh wow
it's cool to see them in practical suits yeah
i will teach you to protect yourself this
really is the mandalorian season three
seriously we'll get back to all that stuff later
we don't need to we know what you guys want
to expect to see you here neither did i i'm an old
friend of the family i thought you weren't going
to help train kroger i'm not master lucas that's
cool she gets to interact with luke what is this
place there's nothing now that will someday be
a great school yeah you should have the greatest
first student oh he's the first okay i don't
understand why you're all right with skywalker's
decision to train the kid when you wouldn't
because it was his choice i don't control the
wants of others then it's my choice to go and
see him hmm of course if that is what you wish
croco i want to give him this
why so he will remember you no
there's a mandalorian foundling
he should have this it's his right
i'm getting emotional under there this
armor will protect him it's like a mithril
thing mm-hmm yeah little chain mail probably
rogan misses you a great deal if he sees you
it will only make things more difficult for him
oh god damn it right now we're soaking right here
make sure he's protected oh
man dude you're the best dad
oh buddy
oh man scared him like yoda
[ __ ] that goddamn freaking show
bend down jump and as you do feel
the force flow through you oh my god
you're trying too hard don't try
come on i want to show you something my
guys are zipping around like superman
hey that's great
now go raise another x-wing at the swamp that's it
very good it's just great puppeteering too
is grogu about to wheel the lightsaber yes
do it oh awesome this is a training remote
it will test your reflexes
there you go you did the jump very good
oh my god
oh my god luke and ahsoka
interacting with each other
you guys interact with each other
say something oh my gosh gonna break it
oh
good now fix it we only have one of those it's
more like he's remembering that i'm actually
teaching him anything sometimes the student
guides the master nice you brought him a gift
sometimes i wonder if this heart
is in it so much like your father
crazy crazy what should i do about him trust
your instincts that will always go well
right but what do you want what's
wrong with you just tell me what you
want right are you acting out you're acting
now give me a mission kill some people okay
this is the mandalorian dinjarin thanks to him
and chris anton we now have enough experienced
muscle to act as enforcers we lack the
numbers to cover our territory if an
all-out war comes we need foot soldiers
i might be able to help with that
call up your boy cobb i like
how that was their reunion
you want to park your starship you got to do it
out there in the flat i'm looking for marshall
vance i don't think you heard what i said
i heard you i'll take it from here deputy
oh you just came out of nowhere hiding behind him
this whole thing we need good people to step up
or the spice is bound to come through these parts
as long as i'm here that's not a problem i fought
side by side with the citizens of freetown and
they're brave people and the pike syndicate has
us outnumbered and we need your help things are
tough around here but i'll see what i can do
get the word out i want all men and women of
fighting age to come to town i won't have a
meeting it's not our problem marshall no but it
might be after they hear what i'm going to say
you already got pikes coming
through this territory
is that cat bait that's just the next best cabin
she gets your list down tell these people to head
inside for a spill something wrong marshall i
hope not i've already sold myself holy [ __ ]
looks like him where's that blue face
no he would kill cobb oh don't no don't kill
cobb though the pike set him oh my god it's him
action campaign
and all you've got to do is stay put and
let things play out don't bully cobb hey the
marshall ain't for sale dude you're gonna get
yourself dude you're gonna get yourself killed
i can't believe this is happening boba a
cold-blooded killer who worked for the empire
oh crap they got a history you should have
never given up your armor no please please god
no no no
do not want
kill that guy cat yeah warning shot
oh definitely oh
as long as the spice keeps running
everyone will be left alone
please please back to tank
it's up to you now barkeep i i can't
believe we got a live action cabin
we might actually see the flashback of the
no maybe we wouldn't i'll say that talk after
slay it all day after you rise it up and
all your next episode cameo wishes out
are they like gigolos too it
really does yeah just like
concubines i feel like american
horror story vibes from this
oh
no
grogu beat ben solo you guys
are going to be bunk mates
the mandalorian wanted you to have this looks
a little small i mean he will eventually
grow out of it before you take it i will
give you a choice this is the blue pill
oh my god damn why are you
doing this tim is a lightsaber
it belonged to my teacher master
yoda i'm offering it to you
i'm just gonna put this one a little closer
if you choose the armor you'll
return to your friend the mandalorian
but if you choose the lightsaber you will be the
first student in my academy and i will train you
to be a great jedi sophie's choice and you
may never see the mandalorian again because
grogu a short time for you is a lifetime for
someone else season three is in your hands child
no
come on felony mum now in the direction too
oh they originally had him and uh they're gonna
like the the ropes that i assume in like last
journey stuff i can't believe boba put this
all in his book willing to share the start
that's great but there are a whole lot of other
main characters i gotta say what
i was saying was that there's um
there's uh some they didn't actually get a
fully bring it to life with cab bait and boba
when they square it off and that's how he has
like a hole in his head or something and so i
was wondering if i see a flashback of that i mean
the future's wide open for something like that now
it's crazy now he looks like
something out of american horse yes
like a menacing alien i love it i mean the first
guy of the default the dark saber was both
he had both let him be both come on man
maybe you should uh play in the gray a little
bit do a little gray jedi action man a second
ass silhouette showed up in that kung fu
western yeah david carradine like talking
i did not see that coming at all
like in that moment especially
uh and i hope i hope somehow
cobb vance is not dead
yes we thought like like they didn't explain
how did bad badge ever explain how he
he just lived because he was presumed dead for
a while but then he came back in bad batch but
what a presence yeah a presence
in just a couple of minutes yeah
it was a great standoff too
just like all that tension
easily the best part was when they check in with
bob oh dude and the mods are back thank goodness
to boba even speak then i think
fennek did all the talking
that's good wow wow that was the episode
right there at some point he's going to
be wearing that me throwing ortix
gonna stab him yeah that's right
boom these last two episodes man that is
so much star wars all they needed was to
make it the mandalorian ladies gentlemen i
uh not gonna be able to talk clearly yeah
that is that was overwhelming would have had
a conflict of emotions at the same time like
just the fan service through the roof while
moving like moving the freaking storyline
goddamn speed force and um and then creating
just like the conflicts of choices it's it's
like freaking like when cat bane shows up it's
like holy [ __ ] we got a cat baby here and
and uh like there's such a history with him
actually i think if i'm not mistaken he was
one of the people who did mentor boba early on
in the days of bounty hunting if i'm not mistaken
so there's such a rich history between them and
the last time they saw each other was via a duel
so you know like there is there's a lot to
mind there and then the second i'm like oh
crap no he might kill cobb damn this is not what
i wanted yeah yeah you were so happy to see this
guy and now he's about to break your heart yeah
and uh because that's yeah campaign's uh he's an
antagonist and to to introduce like that is crazy
and it's what's cool about how they handled it
here i thought was obviously for people who have
like you know seen clone wars or a very minimum
bad match you'll have familiarity with who the
character is but regardless of that the way filoni
and crew framed him here had such a villainous
presence the entire time and he is like menacing
and scary to behold to do anything and i'm glad
they put him in like practical makeup because
yeah that was uncomfortable to look at it and i
loved it i just loved the way he looked and it
just feels like plucked out of there i thought i'd
be a little bluer but he still feels like he's all
blue but i thought he'd be even like bluer yeah
but he still looks so great and it's it's just
awesome to look at but that conflict of choice
and then of course to see like the early days of
luke being like ain't nothing bad gonna happen
here today dude best school known i'm gonna train
all the best jedi it's gonna be awesome um yeah it
makes you do wonder what the future of groku might
be you know like they as they established with um
the original person to wield the darksaber that
was mandalorian and jedi and now uh now he's
giving him a choice and that is so conflicting
you know and i would reckon that he would go
down the path of mandalorian ultimately because
this is our first time hearing of
grogu he's not talked about at all
i mean unless there's just some unfortunate
fate where ben solo did kill him you know
or met he maybe left the school before any of
that happened at this same time like well you know
disney wants to make their money and you want to
keep you want to keep baby yoda on the show with
the jordan right yeah absolutely and it wouldn't
be practical just to always kind of side quest out
to school to go pop in and make sure he's okay
yeah get redundant after a while yeah and then
to finally see like ahsoka and luke interact with
each other the paddle one of anak and skywalker
coming all the way full circle here where they get
to interact with each other like there's no one
other than you know obi-wan there's no one else
who could say of your your lot like your father
in a positive endearing way more so than ahsoka
tano can say and like to get those scenes and then
all the freaking like callbacks and references
and then also still moving the story forward
with training grogu when you're like there's
so much empire strikes back happening right
yeah except it's not like some you know foggy sway
nice it's beautiful to look at and you're watching
him advance and grow and grow growing grogu uh
yeah i i was uh i was very overwhelmed and then
the jarring was like bringing me to tears like
he's wanted nothing like clearly misses grosgu
so much and he just can't say it and he's
just trying to do what's best for him and
he travels all this way literally travels the
galaxy yeah he just outrans space cops to get here
and he waited forever for someone to greet him to
guide him to there and then when he's right there
to see him he doesn't even he doesn't even get a
chance to say anything to him you know um oh that
was that was heartbreaking that could freaking
kill i mean it looks like they killed off cobb
it looks like it i feel like because they lit up
his deputy way more and he got shot in the once
i'm hoping that something happens or next
episode it's revealed that he's all right
uh but i could actually i could see them you know
making cadbane just murk him in cold blood and
give us that much more reason to hate this guy
i think the implementation of the history that
cabin brings via boba fett would really allow us
to see or maybe have some type of scene hopefully
um i really say hopefully because clearly the
last two episodes have been like the best it
shows me um would really allow us to hone in
a little bit more on boba's character change
you know more so than a time spent with the
tuscan raiders really allowing us to understand
perhaps more in depth was he's like saying
pope is a cold-blooded killer and of course
the last time cad bane was hanging out with
bobo yeah that's the version he remembers and
to to have him like warn combat about that but
also the death of khadvan but also cause all
the people who were taking more of a pacifistic
method towards this fight might actually rally
together to help fight and that bartender is
going to become the new sheriff of freetown
yeah but yeah this was like an interesting
episode because like mandalorian feels expansive
to a degree but it also feels like it's its own
kind of niche of the star wars galaxy to me and
then you have this boba fett show which in some
ways has felt like even more of a niche and this
episode sure yeah and this episode really like
the appearance of a character like cad bane even
more so in some degrees than luke just because
we've already seen him here and we've already
seen ahsoka on this program it's like something
about this episode and that especially made it
feel that much more expansive consequential to the
greater picture of things well i felt like we were
watching a star wars movie exactly where the last
one felt like mandalorian season three episode one
this was cutting around to so many different story
lines like a star wars movie it felt like yeah
yeah just like a star wars story and not the book
of boba fett not the mandalorians just were in all
different walks of the star wars world and all of
them are interlocking to some degree and like 10
seconds of boba fett and 10 seconds i'm fascinated
as to how and why the show came together quite the
way it did because for the first four episodes
it makes absolute sense and now i'm like it's the
book of boba fett with a couple issues of a couple
other books slipped in and then it'll kind of come
back to boba fett i imagine by the end of it but
cause even when it cuts back to boba i'm like
apparently this is the least interesting barely
seems concerned with him yeah yeah absolutely
and and you know i i felt that too and that's
coming from somebody who's enjoyed most all the
boba stuff up to this point to some degree i have
i've really enjoyed episodes two and four a lot
and then here but these last two are
just on another level yeah yeah and um
i just feel so much more pertinent for some
reason yeah yeah and uh he's more emotional
and just so much more connected and it feels
more star wars and uh the way the way things
progress with the pikes too you know they actually
brought them to a point that felt menacing that
felt really threatening they blow up that one
freaking bar we keep going back to on tattoo
you know yep straight up blow it to
smithereens yeah man the pike's higher
freaking the syndicate hires goddamn cat
bane poor garcia whipped i mean i thought uh
oh my god what is her name amelia clark here oh
kira kira yeah my god i thought she might show up
um still good uh yeah seeing the
way this [ __ ] is going real crazy
man what harrison ford shows up what if maybe
i mean we got to talk about that luke skywalker
deep fake a little bit because like they hired
shamook i remember i think it was him who they
hired who did like amazing he does amazing deep
fakes on youtube and so and i think one of his
biggest ones was like here's what mandalorian did
with luke here's what i did with the deep fake and
it looks so much better and uh and there are times
where it just looked like like wow this is uncanny
like this is like so crazy yeah like this looks
like so flawless uh and there are times where it
still look like oh this is kind of weird i can
really see that chin shadow you can see you can
really see like that's not mark hamill performing
and they're trying to match the voiceover
yeah there's a lot of dubbing here yeah he has to
keep i thought they split the difference because
when he shows up in mandalorian for the second
season he's very stoic and i thought they did hear
a better job with he's still kind of
straight and a little when i say flat
i mean in the way that star wars dialogue delivery
can be flowers part of the aesthetic i mean
he he delivers every line the same way pretty
much yes exactly yeah yeah but it it was like
yeah while there are seams it was like
wow they have really advanced this effect
and it looks like bottom line it looks way
better than before while it's not perfect for
for a minute there i thought like
they perfected this it's not yeah
but i don't think this will spurn as many
like i did it myself and it's way better
on the internet no and the story is so essential
to be told and they are filling in a very
important gap in star wars lore from what happened
between return of the jedi to the force awakens
with this school that's what i mean it's like this
show has become the springboard for a much bigger
it's like sorry i was so small with the
boba fett [ __ ] and that just gets like
big as hell yeah yeah with everything they're
doing and uh it's like how a soccer was there
just to pay this just literally just to say what's
up tomando what's up to luke and then to leave i'm
gonna go to my other show and look for general
thrawn and then uh you know look for sabine and
as richard i'm gonna get all that going yeah just
to remind you guys i got my own series coming up
i'm here too um but i like the i kind of like
the coldness i don't know if threatens coldness
but the intentional separation the god the
garden nature that luke has towards danjarin
um that detached it's just i feel like luke would
just have a little bit of a different approach
and see i i feel i don't know he's got so
many very important personal attachments
throughout the entire year in his life yes
lady train's laying at one point here right
in one of those skywalker he trains leo one point
um you know he obviously stays connected to the
family so he keeps his attachments yeah um so
maybe that's a part of his journey it's it's like
the last time if like the disney sequels never
came out the live action he was he's just come off
the death of anakin skywalker you know like the
guys at him and he was celebrating with everyone
so the dude's like an emotional dude and uh that
was something that obi wan as really explored
heavily in clone wars was um with bogotan's sister
oh my god what is her name yep joe katana no no no
oh it's really bugging me that it's blood that
i'm throwing like it was such a powerful like he
obviously had a romantic history with her and you
know like that's something he was very much like
drew him a little bit further away like
there's a whole big speech he gives at
one point about like if you had asked me
to give up the jedi order i would have
and you know it's like that's something a jedi
always has to deal with so i thought by this
point luke might be a little bit more towards the
hair look you could have some attachments yeah
and i get the point i i understand the the
thesis of the test but part of me is like
that would come in handy that little bit of
armor and also you know that's what it means
yeah so you you can never circumvent the yeah the
meaning behind it but part of me is like just let
them use it and then just really focus on the jedi
part of the training because they have a debate
with each other about you know like he's a he's
a mandalorian family well maybe he's a patent one
can't be both it was cooled in the flashback
of of grogu where you see the 66 yeah you see
the clone troopers and uh i'm so used to seeing
them as cgi prequels to see them brought to life
and like oh wow look at them they're an actual
costumer yeah yeah for sure and uh yeah that was
intense i i i don't know if gro i mean grog was
already interacted with boba in season two and
so i i thought like if grogu had seen any other
the clone troopers faces he might have been like
ah you look like oh you're all those people trying
to kill me exactly oh no i don't want to help you
i wonder who those jedi were um someone smarter
than ourselves they'll have to tell us in the
comments but they're a very specific jedi this
was uh this was awesome this was something else um
holy [ __ ] i can't believe it um that was and
the music was beautiful and yes it was maloney
killed it this time man he really knocked it out
of the park this is such an oddly shaped show as
a whole but it's been very exciting the way it's
developed some of the best star wars yeah yeah
in recent memory yeah that's all all it had to
do i just had to find their way to tv all right
all right guys well look uh we gotta
start working on actually putting this
video together to get to you guys so uh
thanks for being here and let's do a page
michael b miguel bien yo that's right man you are
the most dedicated person on our patreon right
now as we're shouting this out you're probably
editing your own reaction to boba fett episode
six and hey man even though you are our direct
competition now i just wanted to let you know
that uh you know we're gonna take that
very personally and we're out for you
specifically so any footage from the show you
use we're gonna claim you take that as our own
you know really make sure that you know that this
space is our space all right you are a stranger
from the desert of youtube and you've emerged
to threaten us and we can't have that but uh
anyhow we love you deep down beyond all that
and by the end of this season we will reunite
but for right now the game is afoot be well buddy
happy february that's good thank you it's great